[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
excuse me
do you see this
a quarterly reports on my desk by friday
oh
[Music]
[Music]
my name is guy sunday should be warm and
sunny just a scattering of drive-bys and
i live
in paradise
i've got a best friend this is the
greatest cup of coffee of all time
mondays am i right joe you said it guys
and i work at the bank
i thought i had everything i needed
but then i met her
everybody down on the ground
everybody accept you
please i have a cold fist there's
something inside you guys i don't want
something inside me i expected you to
just follow the rules that you are so
much more than that put these on okay
fine
oh my god
what are these trick glasses or
something
guy there is no easy way to say this
this world it's a video game you're not
real
please
and the guy responsible for this world
was going to destroy it
you've met god yes he's an absolute
troll trolls exist
buddy if we're not real doesn't that
mean that nothing you do matters i am
sitting here with my best friend trying
to help him get through a tough time now
if that's not real i don't know what is
i know this world is just a game for
this place these people that's all i
have
so i'm not gonna be the good guy thanks
guys i'm gonna be the great guy
well enjoy your lifetime supply of
virginity if you go
this whole good guy routine is ruining
the game
terminator it's the first time i've ever
driven a car before i really wish you'd
mentioned that
that actually hurt my hand we can save
our world
but we have to fight together
[Music]
[Applause]
i can't die
[Music]
[Music]
bye